-Our next guest
is an Emmy-nominated actress
you know from TV shows such as
"Unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt"
and "The Office"
and films like
"Bridesmaids"
and "The Stand In."
She stars
in "Home Sweet Home Alone,"
which is now streaming
on Disney+.
Let's take a look.
-So, did you get my voicemail?
-Yes.
All of this happened
in the last two hours?
-Yeah, the doll
is in that house.
I saw him in his jacket.
-Why didn't you did tell me
any of this?
-I thought
I would handle it myself.
-Your way of handling it
was breaking-and-entering?
-Just entering.
I had the key.
-It's still against the law,
Jeff.
-Like a light bulb!
-Oh, my gosh.
This is so terrible.
-♪ All of the other reindeer ♪
-That's why I didn't do it,
Columbo.
-Well, good.
-♪ Like Pinocchio ♪
-♪ Pinocchio ♪
-What are we gonna do,
though, Pam?
We need that doll.
-I know we do, okay?
Just let me think.
-♪ Join in any reindeer games ♪
-Um...
-♪ Like "Monopoly" ♪
That's too late.
-Please welcome back
to the show,
the always wonderful
Ellie Kemper!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-You look a dream!
-Thank you!
This is the first time
I've been out in months.
I feel -- I feel --
It's nice to put on high heels.
-Well, you look wonderful.
You know, I used to not
have to go out to see you.
We used to live in the same
building in New York City.
-Yep.
-You had some very
hurtful opinions about my dog.
[ Laughter ]
-If you could call it a dog,
Seth.
-Well, see, that's --
-No, no. Out of the gate.
-That's the heart
of the hurtful.
[ Laughter ]
-I know.
-Now, I've always
written that off
as you not being a dog person.
-Yep.
-And so then,
I was happy to hear,
because I feel like
it is fair punishment...
-Yep.
-...that your boys
are dog people.
-Very much.
I have two boys, 5 and 2,
and they love dogs.
We do not have a dog.
They love dogs.
I have the nicest neighbors
in the world.
They have the cutest --
a very cute dog named Benny.
-That's even more hurtful to me
that now you're making it clear
you can perceive cuteness
in a dog.
-I am capable of love for dogs
when they pass the grade.
-Deserve it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, sure.
-But this dog --
but I have to tell you --
And we're in Central Park
all the time.
They love, love dogs.
I'm very straightforward
with them -- I'm not going
to have a dog only because
it's a huge responsibility,
as you know better than anyone.
Being the dog, you know,
the owner that you are.
I couldn't think
of another word.
I said, "Yeah, the dog owner."
And so, I'm like --
I'm not even
sugarcoating it for them.
I'm very direct with them.
"I'm sorry, boys."
Like, "You will not have a dog
in your childhood."
It's killer! It's so mean.
-Yeah.
-But I don't want to raise
their hopes only to dash them.
-Right.
-So I'm just, you know...
-But do you feel like
they've accepted this reality?
-Yeah, well, for Christmas.
I think they think a dog
might come for Christmas.
-Okay, gotcha.
-So, no, not completely.
-So, by January, they should be,
like, really buying into
what you've been telling them.
-Exactly, when there is no dog.
-When there's no dog.
-Under the tree.
I'm like, "I wasn't lying."
[ Laughter ]
-So you did --
You shot this in Canada.
-Yes.
-And your husband,
who's an incredibly
talented writer.
-Yeah.
-The two of you had a bit
of help with the kids,
which is necessary.
-Yes.
-You had a nanny.
-We had a nanny.
She was wonderful.
Her name was Beth.
She was from London.
She had a little bit
of Mary Poppins in her.
-Oh, that's good.
-Very good.
She's a pro.
Like, I owe my life to her.
She took such great care
of our kids.
One thing -- this is sort of a
page from my book about dogs --
she was very direct with the
boys about life and coronavirus.
And I had told Beth, I said,
"You know, the boys -- James,"
who's the older ones,
he knows what coronavirus is."
You know, I've told them
it's a cold,
and that we want to be careful
with our germs.
And she was like,
"Right, right."
I said, "But I don't want
to scare him."
And so, I came home, like,
from work one day,
and James was talking about RNA,
and I was like --
She has a background -- She has,
like, a medical background.
Part of her training was,
you know,
attending some sort of
medical school.
And she was so direct.
She's like,
"It's not a cold, James."
[ Laughter ]
"It's much more contagious
than a cold."
And then whatever
RNA plays into,
she gave them the information
on that.
And she absolutely, like,
dealt them the straight story.
He was also very interested
in Greek myths at the time,
and I said,
"We kind of gloss over, like,
the more horrific parts of --"
You know what I mean?
-Yeah, because it gets
pretty gnarly.
-It's very gnarly, very violent.
-Yeah.
-People killing each other
because they slept
with their their mother,
you know, all this stuff.
She's like --
And, again, James came home
one day -- or,
I came home one day,
and he's talking about --
I don't know my Greek myths.
But he's like, "Well, you know,
Zeus, like --"
I was gonna say something
really horrible.
"Zeus, like, killed,
you know, his mother."
I don't know Greek myths.
And I said, "Oh, Beth, you know,
we were glossing over the sort
of, like, more horrible parts."
She's like, "Oh, no.
Why would you do that?"
It was like, she was so --
I appreciated, like,
that tact, I guess,
but they know everything
about everything now.
-I do like that she stood up
for, like, the Greek myths.
-Exactly!
-They have survived
oral tradition for years.
We're not gonna just let you
change them at the last minute.
-Thank you, yeah!
-Also, that's a huge part
of who Zeus is.
-I know.
He kills people!
-He kills people.
-He sleeps with their mothers
and kills people.
-You can't sugarcoat Zeus.
-I know. I know.
No, she was right.
-Do you remember seeing
"Home Alone"
when it came out in 1990?
-Yes, I loved that.
I mean,
it's, like, an iconic movie.
And when we went to see it --
I lived in St. Louis --
we went, I think,
the day after Thanksgiving.
And my Aunt Dot --
that was her name, Aunt Dot.
She was in the car with us.
She was my mom's aunt.
And we went to
the Saint Louis Galleria.
We found a parking spot so close
to the actual mall,
my Aunt Dot said,
"Well, that is the work of God
that we found --"
[ Laughter ]
And even at 8 years --
God does a lot of good things.
I knew he didn't have that much
control over parking spots
even at that age.
But it was, like, a sign
of the good things
that were to come.
Because that movie, like,
it was a packed audience
laughing out loud.
Like, it's one of the most
iconic movies ever.
It was great.
-You sort of --
You and Rob Delaney,
the very funny Rob Delaney,
you sort of step into
the Harry and Marv role.
-Yeah, exactly.
-So sort of evil --
I should say ill befalls you.
-Yes.
-This is -- what has happened
to you in this situation?
-Well, so it's not all
fun and games.
-This is you as Aunt Dot.
-That's me as Aunt Dot.
[ Laughter ]
-Aunt Dots.
-Very good.
Very good.
I'm Aunt --
I'm Aunt Dots there.
And I believe those were,
like, the marks where all my --
I get sort of hit by Nerf darts,
and I think that's where
all the marks were.
But I'm not happy.
I mean, we had a lot of fun
making the movie.
But it wasn't always fun.
I was miserable that day.
-I would imagine.
-Yes.
-This is -- You don't
look happy here. Hold on.
This is not --
I've seen you look happy.
-I know.
-This is --
[ Laughter ]
-You guys -- like, my mug shot.
-This you when me and the dog
got on the elevator,
it feels like.
[ Laughter ]
That was the face
you managed to get.
-It's like, "Again? You're
really pushing this dog on me."
Yeah.
-What about -- I did hear you
laughed harder during
the filming of one scene
than you expected to.
-I know, yeah.
This is a little disgusting --
not disgusting to me.
I'm a -- You've seen a lot.
You have kids.
I don't know what that means.
But I'm a mom.
I've seen a lot, too.
I sometimes laugh
a little too hard.
And there's a scene in a pool,
which was so funny.
The pool was very warm,
it was very comfortable.
It felt like I was just, like,
at a water park,
and Rob was so -- it was funny.
I was sliding and slipping.
And I laughed so hard --
This is the first time
I'm saying this --
I wet my pants in the pool.
[ Laughter ]
And I was too worried
to say anything because, like,
health restrictions, like we'd
have to shut down production.
But it's over now!
I wet the pool!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, my God.
We just love it!
I mean, when we can break
Hollywood stories
on this show...
-That's your M.O.
-That is so important to us.
-I know it is!
-Thank you so much
for being here.
It is always a delight
to see you.
Ellie Kemper.
"Home Sweet Home Alone."
It's streaming now on Disney+.